We do have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two, David P many
voicemails coming in about the news that members
of the squad, including Alexandria Casteo,
Cortez, Congresswoman from New York will be
or already have endorsed Bernie Sanders in
the democratic primary for president.
Uh, here is one perspective that came in via
voicemail.
Hey David, this is billing Cali.
Everyone is making a big deal about AOC endorsing
Bernie and maybe I'm missing something, but
they're so closely politically aligned.
She's basically his protege.
All the Bernie Sanders are going to be supporting
AOC and by first.
So I'm confused as to why, uh, you know, the
YouTube progressive voices and the corporate
media and everything is making such a big
deal.
When I don't know that AOC endorsement is
actually going to bring in new blood to Bernie's
campaign, new voters, new interests or whatever.
It seems to me that it's just solidifying
who the base of Bernie Sanders supporters
are.
Yeah.
Listen that, we talked about this yesterday
on the bonus show.
I'm open to having my mind change, but that
is basically my view.
Bernie has a big deficit to make up mathematically
in the polls.
A lot of the constituency of someone like
AOC who is saying, I'm not sure who I'm going
to vote for, but once AOC tells me who she
endorses, that's who I'm going to go for.
A lot of those people are already supporting
Bernie Sanders and so I don't think that this
is going to move the needle.
Now the ag man called in and he had an even
more cynical approach.
He believes that this endorsement may hurt
Bernie Sanders.
Take a listen to this.
Hey Dave.
I think, um, the squad backing Bernie right
now is going to move the needle, is can move
the needle away from him and that's it.
You're right.
That people that like Bernie already like
or, but people that are middle of the ground,
people that like Bernie and are kind of progressive
are going to see those super liberal economies
backing him and say, no, no, that's too much.
I have to go towards Warren or go towards
Biden.
So it's gonna move the needle away from iden
and the squad, uh, supporting him is right
now going to be the absolute turning points
and it's going to, it's going to be as close
as he's ever come right now.
This is going to be it.
It's going to be Warren and Biden and I hate
that.
I really freaking hate that.
I love him.
He started all of this and he's getting shafted,
but it's going to hurt him.
The squad.
A fellow brother.
Yeah, shallow McMahon.
But I totally disagree with the egg man.
In this case, I don't believe that the AOC
endorsement is going to help Bernie take the
lead in the primary.
But I also don't think the AOC or squad endorsements
are going to turn people away from Bernie
and I, I assume the ag man is joking about,
you know, socialist, communist, whatever in
the squad.
Um, because they're not, at least as far as,
uh, as I've seen, um, all although they certainly
tend towards a, a social democracy and more
worker's rights in any way.
That's not really the issue here.
I don't think that this is an endorsement
that is going to do much one way or the other,
but I am open to having my mind changed.
So let me know if I am misinterpreting this.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about how Elon Musk smoking pot
on Joe Rogan's program somehow ended up costing
taxpayers $5 million.
How is that possible?
We will talk about it.
We will talk about how 34 of the best selling
quote fruit drinks targeted to kids are not
healthy, not a surprise.
And we will also talk about a Chicago teacher's
strike that is about to start, which will
lead hundreds of thousands of kids in limbo.
Pros, cons,
and the impetus for all of this, all of these
great stories and more on today's bonus show
to become a member or a patron to get instant
access.
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].